wearing a Superman shirt is like a
kryptonite for generally speaking
yes a bird a plane masturbating in your
hotel room alone tonight Jeff Ross
out here at South by Southwest I'm gonna
go roast some people on the street who
wants to get roasted
you're like cardi B - oh my gosh you're
like a nubian Annie I'll be your King if
you want I heard a Black Panther this is
black cougar right here we're here with
the South by Southwest math team you
meetin any chicks
it feels like an open-toe battle for you
guys my name is Jeff Marsha what's your
role in all this here it's nice to know
that South by doesn't discriminate
against witches this guy I'm the
security out here you're the security
guy what happened in your life that your
security for food trucks I love your
shirt though I love elephants where'd
you get that Tyler Hannah it comes free
when you bang a fourteen-year-old boy
Spice Girls this is a bland girls
I'm roasting people what are you the
genie from Aladdin oh my god does
anybody have any hand sanitizer from my
entire body hey what's up - where you
going where you're riding to rehab
it looks like a substitute teacher at
Hogwarts piccoli you live through fast
time way to go I like that you have a
blinken's hat and Mary Todd's vagina on
your face look at you Tracy Chapman let
herself go now you look great the ball
can answer your personal questions
Jimmer find the Temple of Doom what
happened what's poppin ladies I don't
want to burst your bubble but nobody's
checking out your Instagram what do you
do for a living
well you're certainly dressed for all my
other jokes are too inappropriate really
I love chicks that can't run away I'll
see ya I'm glad I finally met Bernie
Sanders grandson your mom has never been
more embarrassed you look like a rabbi
from the future that's it
I only roast the ones I love fellas and
you guys